according to a 2015 study by Princeton
economist death rates of white
middle-aged adults in the United States
which is the largest population group in
the US have been rising after declining
for decades now I discussed this with
you last year with 2015 data about this
issue and we have a new study published
this month by the same economists
looking at 2016 data and they are using
government health statistics death
certificates and other economic
indicators and they have pointed out
that mortality rates for white people
are getting worse
all right death rates have been rising
for adults twenty five-plus since the
beginning of the 21st century the death
rates for non-hispanic white people
overall with a high school education or
less are now equal to those of black
people let's put up a graph here and
you'll see that this graph shows that
among people aged 50 to 54 mortality
among black people has been falling
since the year 2000 mortality among
Hispanic people has been falling since
the year 2000 mortality among all white
people has been slowly rising since the
year 2000 and mortality among low
education white people is rising
drastically especially over the last few
years in general mortality rates among
low education white adults have been
going up since 1999 but check out the
next graph where we're comparing
American White's to other countries
you'll also notice some trends if you
look at other countries mortality rates
in the United States have been rising
for white people aged 50 to 54 since the
mid 1990s whereas mortality rates for
white people have been declining in
France Germany UK Canada Australia and
Sweden and in those other countries
mortality among white people is due to
alcohol drugs a suicide and those have
been declining also since 1990 in the US
you've seen a big increase in death due
to
what is called debts of despair right
alcohol drugs and suicide so what is
impacting this the study suggests that
white people with low education had a
sort of heyday in the 1970s where they
had comparatively better jobs they were
relatively physically and mentally
healthier and that since then the low
education white cohort of Americans has
become economically worse off and less
healthy which is understandably
contributing to rising death rates note
that death rates for college educated
white people continue to drop you can't
just attribute this to lower incomes
because black and Hispanic deaths have
been declining over the same period and
those groups have comparatively lower
income than do white people so instead
the study points to what is called
social dysfunction declines in marriages
temporary relationships children out of
wedlock social isolation these are the
hypotheses about the phenomena that are
causing mental and physical health
problems that can lead to substance
abuse that can lead to suicide but
there's something that's not mentioned
here which I think is really really
important wealth inequality bad health
care a situation where access to health
care and even hunger are problems in the
United States this is probably related
to that angst that Trump supporters talk
about who said Trump is going to be the
solution to my problems
the increased death rates of white
people I think tell a big part of the
story that we're seeing around Trump as
well I can absolutely see that and it's
really too bad in a way too because if
this was entirely due to health you
could say all right well people should
start exercising more yep or eat
healthier but it seems like a lot of the
things that are contributing to this are
things that people either can't control
at all or have very little control on
you know health care what what their
income is so it's a much more complex
issue and one that's a lot harder to
solve there is a homogeneous a ssin that
we are seeing because as we see some of
the issues of
white America blend into the issues that
non-white America has been experiencing
higher mortality rates lower incomes etc
when you see low education white America
starting to track more closely I wonder
and this is not me relishing this this
is not a desire it's merely a question
are we going to see a more unified
economic populism demanded that is going
to lead to left wing populism being the
answer because we saw with Trump this
authoritarian regressive right wing
populism resonated with many white
Americans not with non-white Americans
and I'm wondering what we will see over
the next five to 15 years as a result of
these numbers and obviously the
immediate should be how can we start
increasing longevity and decreasing
death rates for all people in the United
States and the thing is when you pull
people on the issues they're by and
large left-wing populist yes so when you
asked if universal health care is
something that they would support they'd
say yes overwhelmingly the same thing
when it comes to taxing the top one
percent and having a progressive tax
system right so they're in favor of
these policies it's just about getting
the right candidate to market that and I
think that's what we had in Bernie
Sanders but unfortunately he came up
short and a lot of it has to do with
just the way you ask questions if you
ask your if you pull all Americans or a
representative sample of Americans and
say do you support government taking
control of healthcare people are
generally not going to be that positive
about that if you say does the
government have a responsibility to
ensure everyone has a basic level of
health care regardless of ability to pay
it's a very similar question in reality
but it's worded very differently support
goes way way up so we know that how
vocabulary ties into your perception of
your own politics has a big big impact
on whether you would support or oppose a
particular policy